i
[Música]
a
más de 9000 migrantes y solicitantes de
asilo se encuentran en estos momentos en
el nuevo campo de kt pere en la isla
griega de lesbos tras que la anterior
estructura fue destruida por un terrible
incendio ocurrido hace unos días de
estos nueve mil dos miles según la
agencia de naciones unidas para los
refugiados ya tienen los requisitos para
obtener el estatus de asilados y ser
trasladados al continente algo que
descongestionaría a las islas griegas y
que también limitaría las posibilidades
de que estas personas se contagien por
coronavirus de hecho de 250 de ellos ya
han dado positivo a esta enfermedad por
también las precarias condiciones en las
que viven hay que recordar que también
hay 400 niños no acompañados es decir
niños que están viajando sin madre mi
padre una situación que provoca
indignación y que también refleja los
tantos años de poca soledad de los
países europeos con estas personas
[Música]
la crisis generalizada en venezuela
llevado en los últimos años a más de 5
millones de habitantes a salir del país
de los cuales 4 millones llegaron a
naciones de américa latina y el caribe
según datos de la oficina del alto
comisionado para los refugiados de las
naciones unidas sin embargo ante la
crisis del cobi 19 cerca de 106 mil
migrantes venezolanos tuvieron que
retornar a su país pese a que no estaba
en sus planes
muchos caminaron desde chile perú
ecuador y colombia sorteando muchas
dificultades entre ellas cambian a la
intemperie sin comida y al llegar a la
frontera venezolana debieron esperar que
el gobierno de nicolás maduro les dejara
ingresar por grupos la mayoría eran el
sostén de sus familias en venezuela y
enviaban dinero medicamentos y alimentos
a las autoridades colombianas
recientemente han dicho que están
alertas ya que tras la reactivación de
la economía en colombia han empezado a
ver los venezolanos movilizándose de
retorno debido a que en venezuela las
condiciones de vida y el acceso al
trabajo aún no han mejorado
[Música]
en eeuu miles de emigrantes
centroamericanos temen ser expulsados
después de que la corte de apelaciones
diera la razón al presidente de donald
trump para cancelar el programa de
protección temporal conocido como tps
para nacionales de países como el
salvador o nicaragua en total hay
300.000 indocumentados la mayoría de
ellos son refugiados y llevan varias
décadas en eeuu el tps les había salvado
muchos habían abandonado sus países
huyendo de las pandillas y porque habían
recibido amenazas de muerte ahora parece
que se ha regresado a la casilla de
salida podrían ser deportados o sus
vidas o las de su familia podrían correr
peligro con todo la pandemia está
jugando en su contra ya que muchos han
perdido su trabajo y no pueden
mantenerse eso ha provocado según
algunas organizaciones proinmigrantes a
que algunos hayan decidido marcharse por
su propio bien ante las negativas
perspectivas económicas
[Música]